hi everyone welcome to our daily live
stream this is something that we started
about two months ago really to stay in
touch during times of social distancing
and physical school closures
obviously we been trying to do a lot of
other things but we thought it's it's
also nice to have interesting guests and
have interesting conversations about the
crisis were going through and beyond I
do like to remind everyone we are a
not-for-profit organization we only
exist because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
donating the Khan Academy I want to give
special thanks to several corporations
that have stepped up in the recent last
several months we were already running
at a deficit before the crisis and it
grew as our server costs grew and we've
been trying to accelerate some programs
forward so special thanks to Bank for
America google.org AT&T fastly and
Novartis and now we're gonna have a new
segment where I'm gonna bring in Dan hi
Dan
to just make a couple of quick
announcements for us all right so we're
super excited to announce the launch of
our spanish-language US site for remote
learning Kahn Costa gamos aprendiendo
the folks our team will be adding the
links to the message boards right now
it's really exciting because not only is
it for our US spanish-speaking folks it
is also an adaptation of our resources
so we didn't just translate we actually
made sure that we were adapting all of
our remote learning resources
appropriately and then another
announcement we wanted to share is that
there will be no homeroom show tomorrow
Sal will be on hey they're human with
Rainn Wilson better known as Dwight
Schrute on soap on pancakes Instagram
channel at noon tomorrow but we will be
back on Thursday for a special Herman
celebrating the graduating class of 2020
so if you know any other graduating
seniors this year please invite them to
join homeroom sounds gonna be sharing
some special messages and the segment's
will be highlighting all the great work
that you all did this past year thanks
Dan I'm I'm mildly entertained and
disturbed by some of those graphics that
I just saw so so thanks Dan and some I'm
super excited for our guests today
superintendent Alberto Carvalho from
miami-dade who you know we've known each
other off and on for for many years now
a super engineer Carvalho thanks for
joining us today
it's a pleasure Sol thank you so much
for the opportunity look forward to the
conversation and can't wait to see you
in cap and gown Thursday
my mom will probably be excited and any
time it looks like I'm getting more
educated so may be a good place to start
before obviously it'll be interesting to
talk about how you all have been
navigating the crisis but you know what
kind of blew my mind was the first time
that we had a chance to really dig in
deeply with everything going on at
miami-dade is you know there's a lot of
narrative of large urban school
districts you know the stereotype is
that it can be a little bit
dysfunctional a little bit slow-moving
and I think and you know I told this
other people when you're not in the room
something you all have done at
miami-dade it's it seems pretty
incredible tell us kind of the
transformation of miami-dade and where
you all have gotten with things like
graduation rates and other measures it's
very interesting we're having that
conversation now in the middle of a
crisis because I'm a crisis
superintendent I started back back in
2008-2009 as superintendent at the onset
of one of the greatest recessions this
nation ever went through and quite
frankly within that crisis there was an
opportunity and then we'll go back to
how we're finding the opportunity
wrapped you know in in today's crisis
but you know when I started as
superintendent this was a district where
only 30 percent of the students were
taking advantage of choice programs
particularly advanced academic choice
programs a graduation rate but what is
this choice program just for those of us
at Tennessee magnet school sinkage
single gender schools career academies
anything but a traditional school
environment so graduation rates were at
56% district-wide but behind that
curtain of general performance there
were some high schools where the
graduation rate was as low as 35% the
shame of our community we had nine
schools under a threat of shut down by
the state of floor
because of performance because for as
long as there was an accountability
system there these schools had never
posted anything higher better than the D
or an F there were literally high
schools in miami-dade where zero
students were taking advantage of
advanced placement classes IB or
Cambridge and that was reasonably
disturbing and of course on the national
setting
I don't think miami-dade was necessarily
moving the needle you you fast forward
and a decade later seventy-three percent
of our students are enrolled in
non-traditional programs that means
parents and students are making choices
about the types of programs modality of
learning something that actually excites
them if they want robotics coding
performing visual arts as cybersecurity
there's something for everyone a one
size fits none in miami-dade over one
thousand choice programs one thousand
parental options for kids in miami-dade
secondly for the second year in a row we
are an a-rated school system in the
state of Florida the highest level
performance three years in a row 0f
rated schools graduation rate this year
at ninety percent from 56% and zero
school with a graduation rate below
eighty percent the school that used to
have a graduation rate than thirty five
percentage today at eighty percent and
the most remarkable thing is during that
time period we became better you know
during times of crisis we had a chance
of reinventing ourselves into a better
version of us discarding a lot of the
the debt would slaying a lot of sacred
cows that you know anchor the status quo
really well reinvented the school system
through digital convergence that's why
we were so prepared for our transition
to distance learning because we passed a
remarkable bond referendum back in 2012
for 1.2 billion dollars 250 million of
which were spent in technology and that
was really revolutionary in miami-dade
from curating developing acquiring
applique
content digital content that's
personalized and adaptive to ubiquitous
Universal Wi-Fi guarantee expanded
bandwidth across the board and then the
device conversation we're not using bond
referendums dollars because I don't
believe in mortgaging for 30 years an
asset whose life span is two and a half
to three years but we've acquired an
excess of 300 thousand devices and
that's where we are today
you know broad winning district one of
the highest performing urban districts
in the country with the highest
percentage of Cambridge passing rate AP
passing rate and when you look at who we
are a minority district ninety-five
percent minority yeah seventy-five
percent poor fifty percent of our
student body is immigrant eighty
thousand of our kids are English
language learners a lot of people would
say can't be done but we have shown that
the impossible can become D inevitable
right here in sunny South Florida and I
want to double click on that before we
even get to the present because you know
when I remember when I first learned
these you know for those of you who are
listening who are not familiar with data
from public schools and large urban
school districts what a superintendent
Carvalho just described it's not usual
this is this is a major transformation
that a lot of people talk about what in
your mind super inter Cavallo I mean
even from your from a leadership point
of view or what other stakeholders are
bringing the table what allowed you to
do this why can't we do this in every
city in the country or in the world or
what would have to happen or what should
the leaders be doing you know that's
that happened yeah that's a question I'm
most asked everywhere I go when I give a
speech when I teach at Harvard everybody
always asks me that and and the answer
that I give is really fundamentally
based on five simple points and the
conclusion is that if this is really not
that hard of work it's no longer a skill
set that impairs or prevents others from
replicating these results it's really a
we'll set proposition
they have like yeah you have the
political courage to actually
I embrace the work and the practice with
a degree of abandonment take risks and
do right by kids while sometimes working
the adults respecting the adults but
sometimes working the adults and
certainly we've done that here so the
five things number one leadership
matters and shortly after I became
superintendent I am principals are
directly accountable to me and I have to
tell you that and I don't say this with
pride that I removed replaced demoted
terminated promoted 85% of all
principals in the fourth largest school
system in America and there's a reason
for that I was looking for data-driven
courageous instructional leaders who are
community minded and are risk takers
themselves who can navigate complex data
systems can identify gaps before they
materialize and develop strategies to
address them and that's the profile of
the leader that I want secondly the
reason why leadership school leadership
is so important is because in miami-dade
and I believe this is a good practice we
screen teachers but principals hire
teachers so the hiring of teachers you
know the building block of public
education is done at the school site so
I put a lot of trust in my instructional
leaders my captain's who are principals
and that is the second critical element
is effective strategic data-driven
teaching that is differentiated that
utilizes all the assets we have that
that complements the leadership style of
the principals we hired the third one is
in fact digital convergence and for me
this was our way of tackling a huge
inequity that exists at prior to our
work here which by the way America came
face to face with it during this
pandemic crisis which is digital
inequity the fact that across the
country by zip code people finally
became aware of what they already knew
that there are a lot of digital deserts
and what digital deserts do to poor kids
particularly is it limits their ability
to learn they're learning
is limited in the bell-to-bell time they
have in school why they don't have a
device at home they don't have
connectivity at home so our digital
convergence effort which began in
2012-2013 empowered us with the ability
to actually create a portal of learning
for the most fragile kids by giving them
a device personalized content
applications and connectivity if they
need it and by the way developing a
parent Academy to orient parents in
assisting their kids from home
that's number that's number three number
four is parental engagement and and by
the way I leave it for number four
because I can't change the parent as
much as I can change the child but I can
influence the parent and our launch of
the parent Academy as a college for
parents number went to help parents help
their own kids navigate schooling second
empower parents with skill sets to get
them a job in our own school system in
our Technical College's and thirdly
empower parents in an immigrant
community to be civic minded know their
rights know the laws take advantage of
the protections are afforded them but
the real reason for the parent Academy
and this hurts the feelings of some
educators out there in America is I want
to make parents dangerous you know just
like the law of economic supply and
demand you know we all know communities
that are demand sided in terms their
parents
others are supply side demand sided
commuters it's those communities
reasonably affluent parents know exactly
where the best school the best program
the best principal the best teacher and
they demand that their kid be in it then
you have certain communities where
parents unfortunately don't really know
what to ask for they supply with our
children with a hope and prayer and wish
that you do something right by them so
part of my theory of action here is I
want to feel pressure from communities
that have not necessarily expressed
their discontent sometimes what happens
with their children's school that's
empowering parents and then the last
element
is effective targeted strategic human
capital development professional
development really retooling re-skilling
the workforce that we have look you
cannot go out there and trade your arm
by the way my army is fantastic so it's
hiring the right people but it's also
accelerating the pace that you
transition the army of employees you
have particularly teachers and support
staff into a new way of thinking a new
way of teaching a new way of supporting
a new way of using data new way of using
technology you do those five and I
guarantee you any school system rural
urban small large will prosper now those
are great and we're getting a lot of
questions showing up on YouTube and
Facebook before I go into that I
actually have a leadership question and
also before we talk about the kovat
crisis yeah you know you talk about
those five things and they make a ton of
sense but the I love your phrase with
the the will set the willpower to do it
you know to go in as a new
superintendent and to you know make some
of these changes some of them quite
dramatic that it's easier said than done
you know I'm curious from a personal
level what went through your head is
there sometimes we say hey mate Alberto
maybe I'm I'm the wrong one maybe I
shouldn't rock the boat too much maybe I
should just kind of play nice I mean how
do you because I weigh those things all
the time sometimes I feel conviction
about something but I'm the only person
who believes I'm like maybe I should
just back off a little bit well I'll
tell you a funny story cell number one I
do believe in working at the edge of the
abyss because if you if you don't know
how how did the gap where our kids live
is and you don't know until you get
really close to it and you don't get
really close to it unless you take
humans risks so when I talk about
abandonment yeah I'm talking about
abandonment for the for the position
that I hold I risk the position I try
very hard I tell this to people all the
time to get fired and it is in that
precious moment where you flirt with
termination that something big happens
for the district if it's big enough for
you to make a personal bet in trust me
things will happen and that happened
quite frankly within two weeks of being
appointed superintendent goes directly
to your question
look remember the nine schools they were
gonna be shot down by the state of
Florida for performance and by the way
these were all black and brown schools
in high poverty areas if you shut down
the school for performance the only
thing that will be on that street will
be a liquor store a pawn shop maybe a
church and the beacon of hope and
opportunity for that community is
extinguished
I was not going to do that okay there
was a greater chance of the crown of
Spain of reclaiming Florida than me
giving up on these schools so I brought
the nine principals of the schools one
at a time to have a conversation with me
and I had a conversation with them ask
them all the questions they had been
there for a long period of time and the
one question they all across the board
failed was when I asked him why don't
you have a single AP class ap Literature
AP physics chemistry give me something
AP Spanish and across the board the
answer was you know I'd love to but I
don't have kids for that at that point I
didn't have a job for them I fired nine
principles well nobody had told me that
over the previous 90 years the school
system had not fired
nine principles and I remember the board
chair at that time taking me aside and
said and saying to me two weeks in you
know I regret voting for you as
superintendent you fired my friends now
it burnt it was rough but I survived and
once you go through those experiences
you build resiliency when you time that
with the window of opportunity and by
the way those don't just come once in a
lifetime they happen they happen
cyclically we have one happening right
now a window of opportunity then you can
get really crazy good things done not
the void of threat or challenge but if
you're grounded in that which is right
then you take on the sacred cows you
take on the political establishment and
you force through that which you know
will actually pay off for kids do I
worry sometimes I myself not as much
sometimes my team does sometimes my wife
may a bit
but I feel the communities on our site
we're very transparent I tell the story
all the time the media believe it or not
twelve years in I don't complain about
the media the print media TV media
because they recognize that we leave it
all out there so yeah there are some
tough times but there are enough people
in this community who are awake and
support the work and provide a cover for
the work to continue
that's super powerful just you know do
it right and the chips fall where they
do even for yourself versus you know
preserving a job or title or whatever is
expedient I think it's a very powerful
notion a lot of folks out there do what
I do that never true never really risk
that much out of fear of pushing the
envelope too far and you know what
happens they end up losing the job
because the performance never increases
and so at least you know lose your job
doing something big bold and right that
actually moves the needle because they
have greater chances of actually keeping
your job if the needle moves because
people pay attention so you know that to
me it's it's my theory of action and
it's it's worked
I recommend it strongly to those who you
know who don't mind you know feeling the
pressure it comes with a territory but
it's work for us that's that's
fascinating so I'm going to some of
these questions and really get more to
the present you know
Susanna Garcia Dominguez on YouTube is
asking greetings supernet Carvalho what
are your takeaways from this pandemic
crisis from we have another one from I
just thought of it just disappeared
where a student was asking about just
how are you navigating the crisis so
yeah
play it out for us huh you know how did
this all evolve in Miami over the last I
guess two and a half months when it
started to become clear that we might
have to have to close yeah so you may
find this incredible but we did not wait
on the federal government or a state of
Florida to tell us to provide his
directives on how to prepare for what
was inevitable actually I remember us
back in January simultaneously and we
were digesting headlines out of
and I had just watched a series on
Netflix dealing with a pandemic and and
I connected it to a week later
coronavirus is on my leadership agenda
to be discussed with my cabinet and a
few weeks later we were reading a survey
for parents to determine what the
critical technology needs were at home
why because we put on the board the
worst case scenario to solve for and
that worst case scenario is all schools
going to shut down 355,000 k-12 kids
going to be home in addition to 40,000
adult learners 48,000 employees will be
home what are you gonna do what's our
solution for that
so we bet on the worst case scenario and
one wasn't because this in in February
or January process anywhere you were
you're having this conversation Jay no
one was talking about school closures no
while you write know we we began a
contingency plan in January February we
began to actually write the plan by
before two weeks before the shutdown we
had the first version of our
instructional continuity plan which was
followed by an ICP 2.0 and much more
evolved with student and teacher
accountability look we shut down schools
with we shut down schools with an L owe
you a negotiated agreement with the
teachers union agreeing to
accountability you know number of hours
that were expecting terms of
responsiveness to students and
connectivity in connection the same
thing attendance for students and we
didn't have to do this on the back end
before we shut down schools we had
already developed webinars for teachers
we had already put 100 percent of our
teachers through professional
development which was not difficult
because they were already using the same
applications the same devices in the
classroom that now the kids and the
teachers themselves were using at home
the geography changed but nothing else
did the survey results empowered us with
the
to actually know exactly who needed a
device who needed a hotspot so when we
began the distribution 119,000 devices
hit the hands of kids quickly eleven
thousand hot spots 100 percent
connectivity of miami-dade and by the
way and this is still right now average
daily attendance hold on America 91 to
92 percent that's about one to two
percent away from a typical day last
year round this time because we prepare
it
we were not waiting on the federal
government to say it's time to go now we
anticipated worst-case scenario and we
prepared for it hoping for the best and
that's exactly what we're doing right
now by the way for the reopening come
August 20 we are you know these days
it's less less about strategic planning
it's more about active strategic
thinking that is nimble that is Swift
that can pivot on the basis of
environmental changes in our communities
and I think leadership today is having a
number of contingency plans ready to
jump to depending on conditions as they
emerge between now and the reopening of
schools however that happens in August
and that's exactly what we're doing
we were not waiting from from the
landlord to tell us when to rearrange
the furniture at our level we got ready
for that and there's several things I
mean we could we could double-click on a
lot of what you just said but I'm
curious how you were able to so quickly
and it sounds like one of your
advantages you you saw it coming and you
planned ahead but you know just the
devices that you mentioned 100 something
thousand devices a large chunk of the
students I mean it sounds like you've
kind of closed the digital divide in
your community somewhat you know not
overnight but over a few weeks how did
you pull how did you pull that off data
data data you know data is part of our
DNA is our North Star we have an equity
mindset we knew exactly where the
opportunity gaps were for kids and we
planned to a
in a very strategic methodical
procedural way and and you're right as
far as the data that we manage daily and
every single day at 9:00 a.m. I get the
reports from my senior team before we
start today via zoom conversation that
looks at system-wide performance but
then looks at this aggregated data for
the lowest 25% of students in terms of
reading proficiency for English language
learners for students with disabilities
for the immigrant child I get all of
those reports in addition to attendance
for every one of these groups so we can
very very quickly address the pockets of
low performance or the outliers I mean
there was a point where we had students
who were unaccounted for guess what we
used wellness checks even our own Police
Department with a knock on the door a
social worker a device in the bag with
easy instructions we leverage the fact
that we continued to feed kids and again
buckle your seatbelt it once again as of
today we fed 2.9 million meals out of 50
centers we do it twice a week for every
single day for every single kid no
questions asked that comes to our
schools but in addition to that because
we know that some kids live in really
harsh conditions facing food insecurity
in their zip codes we embrace and
embarked on this community feeding
project not using taxpayers money but
through our foundation capturing money
then putting small restaurants to work
to prepare meals to distribute to the
zip codes where we had the highest
poverty overlaid over this grid that
demonstrated the largest concentration
of poor kids so have we have we filled
or narrowed some of the gaps in some
cases we obliterated the gap in many
cases it's work in progress but it's
what we're doing now quite frankly as we
wrap up their school year and the end of
next school year that I'm excited and if
we have a chance of
like to talk about it ya know we got a
bunch of questions there from YouTube
Charlotte sometimes what is the plan for
next school year will only be digital or
will be mixed learning Kim darling from
YouTube
do you anticipate going back to school
or yes oh so to speak to that
what are the contingency plans y'all are
thinking of so number one I have
absolutely expectation I'm the eternal
optimist kids will go back to schooling
now going back to school and when that's
a function since I'm a science driven
guy you know my my degree is in in in
biomedical sciences with a minor in
physics I have no choice it's in my DNA
to decode science and use it to inform
the practice so what I can tell you
right now is what we're doing really you
know in a very proud and deliberate way
is dealing with America will experience
very soon which is the largest
precedent-setting historic academic
regression the likes of which the
nation's never seen and by the way it's
going to impact this proportionally the
kids who were always at the bottom to
begin with these are by the way the kids
who before the crisis were already in
crisis which is interesting right there
were a lot of kids amongst us before
Kovac 19 crisis they were already
experiencing a multi-faceted crisis on a
daily basis so for us this is the
educational opportunity hidden in this
health crisis and it it begins with two
summer sessions and by the way all of
our budgets going to be hit hard but
this is my priority budget before my
board to summer sessions the very first
one is a virtual session the targeting
students already identified on the basis
of performance on the basis of fragility
on the basis of their lackluster
connection during distance learning on
the basis of formative assessment data
the second summer session may be virtual
or should conditions improve
significantly we may bring students into
schools in small groups small ratios for
very individualized attend
by teachers credit recovery students
with disabilities immigrant students and
the like then we already budgeted for
and planned for the next school year to
start two weeks earlier for 25% of our
student population that's 46,000
students opening all schools taught by
selected teachers who have a high record
of success with these minority
populations with these struggling
students next virtual mentors and tutors
for every single kid next for 25 schools
they have the greatest percentage of
these fragile children one our added at
the end of the day a four additional
opportunity to catch up what I'm
describing here is the opportunity for
us is to academically stabilize these
kids who historically have foam behind
by the end of the twenty twenty twenty
twenty one school year now what will
school look like next year guess what
America since this insular knee became a
reality across all 50 50 states parents
have had a unique opportunity to have a
front-row seat and observe the whole
show they have been monitoring what's
happening in their kids education they
have made judgments evaluated the
experience they have determined how
responsive the teacher was or wasn't
they know the level of engagement of
their own children and I think parents
as a result of this are not going to
give up that knowledge so that's why
this new norm well everybody keeps
talking about it's real parents will be
more demanding and I think they'll be
more demanding in terms of expectations
for their children but now that they
know that it is possible my prediction
is and this is what we're planning for
in miami-dade again one size fits none
is a very flexible opportunity to
schedule students and teach students on
the basis of individual student modality
flexibility and demand on a parents life
the logistics that will condition our
social distancing measuring if
temperature kids going into schools
having to reconfigure schools the way
for example you feed probably you're not
going to be able to congregate kids in a
cafeteria so food will be distributed to
each classroom like uber eats to the
classroom
unidirectional hallways to reduce
contact cyclical mandatory washing of
hands much stronger systems for illness
detection and reporting but what I'm
excited about quite frankly is the fact
that we will see in my opinion an
explosion of hybrid and blended learning
models and I'll just give you an example
three examples will Johnny because a
parental circumstances or the fact that
is a highly social being wants to be in
school 100% at the time our school
system ought to be able to deliver that
Mary on the other hand may say you know
what my parents one parent is at home
part of the time and I'd like to be home
part of the time so I would like to be
on Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays at
home on Tuesdays and Thursdays actually
at school we can do that too why not
then there may be yet another child who
for a whole host of reasons may say I
actually thrive in this environment and
I want to make school visitations I want
to take advantage of some of the
programs athletics etc but I feel safer
at least for a the beginning of the year
based on parental concerns staying home
and learning from a distance what I just
described this sort of a spectrum of
opportunity that is choice driven
identifies the needs of parents and
students and tries to match them with
individualized learning pathways there
are suited and suitable for each kid and
I think that's what's going to explode
it's sort of the new dimension of choice
in America the super powerful because if
you take it one intellectual step from
there that means that even the physical
experiences will have to support the
virtual and that to some degree you're
not necessarily bound to one physical
location anymore in theory that is
absolutely right and
I'm already writing letters and
advocating based on the experience we've
had I think state houses and the federal
government needs to rethink a number of
things number one how education is
funded I mean I think we're proving that
having everybody start at the same time
in at the same time for the exact same
number of minutes every single day in
the same place doesn't work anymore
so we need to liberalize funding
methodology for public education across
the country so that mandated seat time
is not a mandatory feature in in student
funding secondly the how when how by by
whom and how often something is taught
and what is thought needs to be looked
at as well and and I think that what we
have learned under duress
right in the rush can now over the
summer any months to come be analyzed
and let's use some of the learnings from
this experience to actually enhance the
student experience moving forward and I
think that's reasonably powerful Wow
well you know superintendent Carvalho I
could talk to you for a few more hours
actually want to take notes on a lot of
this because what you're doing I mean at
a very large scale with a complex School
District and there's a lot more house
there's a lot of questions how are you
able to pull this off you know what
you're saying makes so much intellectual
sense but you know the timeframes and
obviously the dollars where are you
getting the resources to do it
you know I guess you're willing to stake
your job on a lot of things we talked
about that so that's the will I mean I
actually just answered a few if you have
a couple of more minutes I'd love you
know how are you able to do this how are
you able to do these programs you where
you finding the resources what you're
talking about places are like oh we
don't have an extra penny we're already
you know over our heads in terms of
budget yeah well you know I think real
number one let's recognize that the the
fiscal shock that our nation is about to
experience the fiscal shock that the
public education systems across America
are about to face is going to be a
daunting one but we've been there before
probably not to this degree so you know
I don't want to give Tallahassee Mike
or Washington DC a pass during the last
economic recession under stimulus
packages back then over one hundred
fifteen billion dollars were
appropriated to stabilize educational
opportunities across the country so far
under the cares act the current federal
stimulus package is only sixteen billion
dollars have been earmarked and trust me
by all accounts you know and we read
Moody's Analytics as often as we
possibly can the prediction is that
what's coming is a more powerful
longer-lasting economic recession than
the Great Recession of 2008 9 so the
federal government needs to do quite a
bit more at the same time I'm one who
believes that that reductions across the
board don't require leadership so even
during tough times
you ought to prioritize that which is
most important and that's where we start
we follow something we branded here in
Miami which is values based zero based
budgeting each year each year starts at
zero with the highest priorities being
funded first everything else a second
there and that's exactly what we're
doing we are preparing for for this
fiscal shock so we turned off the you
know the the spending rivers long ago
non-essential hiring stopped procurement
stopped renegotiation of private sector
contracts at a discount 10% minimally
because whatever cost whatever the cost
was for something a service or a good
three months ago it's not the same today
you know as a nation we went from 3%
unemployment to over 20 percent in six
weeks everything has changed which means
we need to change so we will face the
fiscal crisis we have and have amassed
reasonable reserves and we pass two Bond
referenda that have secured teacher
salaries in a very significant way we
boosted our teacher salaries last year
anywhere from 14 to 23 percent and
include security
that's not in danger because the funding
stream for that is property tax based
not state revenue so that's gonna remain
stable our investment technology is
going to remain stable or upkeep of our
school is going to remain stable because
we saw the need to help ourselves
operations yes we will depend on state
and federal revenues and we're working
those as well
but there's always an opportunity to
prioritize that which is important in a
budget we don't believe in five percent
across the board ten percent across the
board in fact during times of recession
it is customary for us to actually
augment funding for certain critical
priorities like what we're doing for the
fragile student population rather than
shying away from it
obviously other areas will have to be
cut but those are judgement calls in a
basis of priorities and and that's what
leaders right now in America should be
doing you know what's most important
what are the priorities what are the
gaps that if you don't address them
right now will grow dramatically between
now and August at 2020 making it more
expensive for you to engage in the
remediation which I don't believe in
remediation I believe in accelerating
towards every child's potential but
those are the considerations and that's
how we're doing it we're navigating the
same waters but we we have a different
cell a different rudder and we're
reading the stars in different ways Wow
well that's super inspiring and you know
I think as we go through tough times
whether it's in a school system your
superintendent out there or you're just
a leader and anything I think there's
there's been a lot of really powerful
takeaways so so thank you so much
superintendent Carvalho I hope we can
continue this conversation especially
over the next few months I would love to
learn how all of this evolves and I
think you're really on the the cutting
edge of thinking through how this is
going to play out thank you so much
so really appreciating you've been a
terrific partner let's continue to do
what we do not only with Khan Academy
but with the College Board the Council
of great city schools and to all the
educators out there listen schooling
will resume and it is important for us
to be a steady stream of normalcy for
for kids
not only intellectually academically but
also socially and emotionally and if he
cannot do it face to face there are
means by which today using technology he
can do it from a distance and that's
what we've been doing so good luck to
all of you and talk to you soon
thank you so much thank you well well
thank you everyone for joining hopefully
you're as inspired as I was by talking
to superintendent Carvalho I think not
just a lessons on where we're going on
the education front but frankly
leadership lessons I thought were pretty
profound so thank you so much and as Dan
mentioned we're not gonna be there
tomorrow I'm gonna I'm a bit obviously
been a big office fan so I'm excited to
meet Rainn Wilson or also known as
Dwight rude tomorrow so that should be
entertaining and then we'll resume
backup I think on Thursday but either
way everyone have a good evening and
I'll see you one way or the other
tomorrow
you